the night of Christmas the queen of
Coachella Halloween and now Christmas
this movie the way that I describe it is
just dreamy that's how I felt watching
it it was just beautiful and it gave me
all the feels what was it like being a
part of it and filming it it is just fun
it was a really good time I mean we
definitely got to create a community for
ourselves that was safe and friendly and
warm and just a great space to create we
had the best time yeah yeah I would say
it's kind of such a jolly film and the
subject matter is just you know
heartwarming and to try and spread good
care among people so to be on set and
trying to create that and being a part
of such just you know I'm like nice
moments I was was just it was some
really lovely experience to be a part
I'm broke charmed so called Christopher
Frederick Lyons of Norwich at your
service milady
oh boy there's something about the
holidays and romance that I think just
go together so nicely do you guys
consider yourselves romantic people and
does it come out even more during the
holiday time I think I can be romantic
yeah yeah and when it comes around to it
I like to pull my thumb out yeah thank
you are you are you a grand gestures
during the holidays kind of guy I've
done some grand gestures before yeah I
did a treasure hunt once on a
Valentine's Day how did it go it went
great apart from the rain oh but it was
still it kind of made it real more
romantic that it was raining in a way
yeah yeah for sure I am 100% a hopeless
romantic I'm like working all through
the holidays this year though so I'm
trying to like shut that piece of myself
off get a chance to celebrate whether
it's like in the middle of November or
in January yeah yeah yeah I'll celebrate
like Christmas on Christmas but I I'm a
sucker for extending holidays and
feeling the spirit because I mean like
yes the day of that holiday is nice but
it's the time leading up to it that you
really get to enjoy it with everybody so
yeah I you know circle is one of the
most lovable characters that I've seen
on screen in a long time and he gives he
gives Lady Brooke he gives Lady Brooke
so many reasons to fall in love with him
I know
you have your own knight in shining
armor what are some of the reasons that
that making you feel just kind of like
Gideon and have all the feels think
about your night I know he's one of a
kind he's a really special pie but I
think that that's what's so sweet about
this film is like it doesn't matter who
you are doesn't matter how he old you
are it's like the knight in shining
armor is such a classic thing to to fall
in love with and to be able to
experience that day this film is really
fun yeah and how about you is there
anyone special you're spending the
holidays with this year yes yes yes do
you have plans or traditions you're
looking forward to doing together um
it's tricky because we're bicoastal but
you know I I think always I know you are
a fan of a flashback and yes so I
brought you one we dug deep in the et
yeah yeah yeah good and we found this
little gem from 2006 I think you're
gonna get a kick out of it you get it
today so well kiss that bad really
oh it is amazing like really I did not
think anything of it and I was amazed
that it was still our seat because I
mean I'm not clashing myself adjectives
new kid but people know me from the
Disney Channel and for it to go
mainstream and able to come out here and
like go crazy oh yeah where does that
come from the whole 6e siren vixen thing
where does that come from and C and C
mic drop so happy because I'm like yes I
and still that same girl I love that
they must be so happy I mean you would
just put out your first single yeah at
that moment and I mean you've had so
much success over the past decade what
does that mean to you um I don't know
it's really weird I can't I can't stop
to think about it or try to actually
think wrap my head around it kind of
like broken this film um because it's a
it's a lot I mean I've always dreamt of
doing what I am doing and now I'm doing
it constantly it's just crazy to think
about the journey and how far I've come
and how much further I still want to go
is there any words of wisdom you would
have given that girl she feels pretty
confident is living her best life I am
proud of her yeah it's do your thing
your fans would kill me if I didn't ask
you would just put out your first single
here hmm are you working on new music
I'm not at the moment I'm so busy right
now filming different thing yes but like
that's not that's not on the horizon
anytime soon but who knows like I love
music and I love singing and we saw on
Instagram we know we want more we want
more you're also a musician you know how
are you balancing kind of like this huge
career as an actor on the rise but also
still like finessing the love for music
that you have kind of just making music
without doing gigs because it's too hard
to get to the gigs because you might end
up on a set or something so I'm afraid
of booking in shows but from that just
working on recording stuff puttin that
out so people can hear it good cuz we
love it and you actually have a song on
the soundtrack that's true which is
really exciting yeah yeah I'm so excited
I was thrilled thrilled to be able to
have my own muse that's just a dream
really to be out of something that I've
written and see it along to picture in
something that much the N as well and
see it also is you know so nice to see
such a finished product together with so
many areas of things that you
I love it well I just want to let you
know you are one of our favorites a TT
of new actors that were loving watching
rise but we're so excited about the game
of Thrones prequel I was - can you tell
us can you share a message to fans who
were really excited about that yeah sure
I mean I just well I just not really for
me to explain what happened because you
know it was all so deep in the depths of
the worlds of production but you know I
just I was just truly honored and
grateful to be to be even considered for
something so amazing they've got another
prequel that's happening it was between
two and one had to drop off so they've
still got some great game of Thrones
material coming their way
want you to jump ship is there a chance
that you could jump on board that cast
oh that's not up to me I'm afraid but
would you yeah you're down yeah I'm down
send it the first time yeah why not
[Music]